SUBCOMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND RESPONSE THE
CLOVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN
ADHERENCE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS A
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PROCESSES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CAN CONTINUE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEES TO HEARING TODAY IN
THE CAPITAL- AND ALL MEMBERS
WILL BE PRESENT IN THE HEARING
ROOM AS I UNDERSTAND IT. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL OR WE WILL
ALL BE THIS WILL BE A VOTE ONLY
A HEARING WITH NO DISCUSSION.
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSION ON ALL
THESE ITEMS PREVIOUSLY TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ASSET ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW IT WILL ALSO
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. BRENDA ALL INDIVIDUAL
WISHING TO BE TESTIFIED TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER.
IS A IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND WILL BE DISPLAYED
NOW ON THE SCREEN. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT. THE NUMBER TODAY
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO
SIX. EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE ONE SEVEN
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN ONE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT YOU SHUT OFF
WHATEVER DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON BEFORE YOU BEGIN
YOUR TESTIMONY. I WILL REMAIN
DECORUM AS IS NECESSARY IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ANYBODY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE. MAY HAVE THEIR
MIKES MUTED. WITH EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS THERE COULD BE SOME LAG
TIME SO WE ASKED PEOPLE TO BE
PATIENT. BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CALL-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EVENT HERE. MELINDA'S. WHAT IS
YOUR- IN ORDER TO GET THEM HERE
WE'LL. WELL REMEMBERS OUR
PRESENT- AND A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED IN TODAY'S HEARING
AGAIN WILL BE VOTING ON VARIOUS
PROPOSALS THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HAS HEARD IT DISCUSSED EARLIER
IN THE YEAR. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE'RE GONNA HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT FIRST AND THEN WE WILL
COME BACK TO VOTE ON THE ITEMS.
THAT HAVE BEEN GROUPED TOGETHER
AND FOR US TO VOTE ON- NOW WE
WANT TO PROVIDE. A TIME FOR
ANYBODY WHO HAS PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ANYTHING THAT WE'RE VOTING
ON TODAY- AND AS A REMINDER
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE ONE SEVEN
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN ONE- TURMEL
INDUSTRY HAVE YOU MIKE UP. YES
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU COULD
INDULGE ME JUST FROM AND I JUST
HAD A BRIEF STATEMENT THAT I
WANTED TO MAKE BEFORE WE GOT
STARTED. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
SO MUCH- SO FOR THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THERE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT IS NOT ON
OUR AGENDA TODAY- THAT I FEEL
SHOULD BE A HIGH PRIORITY IN
THIS BUDGET AND I AM TALKING
ABOUT THE MONEY. THAT THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN PROVIDER RATE
STUDY SHOWS IS NEEDED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN DDS ISSUED A
STUDY THAT ESTIMATED SERVICE
PROVIDERS WERE UNDER FUNDEDBY
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION EVERY
YEAR. THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
BUDGET THEN PROVIDED LESS THAN
25% OF THAT AMOUNT AND SO NOW
THE GAP IS AROUND EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION GENERAL FUND- THE
AMOUNT IS NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES HAVE
QUALITY SERVICES IN PLACE TO
HELP THEM LIVE INDEPENDENTLY.
AND IT IS DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE MAY REVISE
HAS NO PROPOSAL TO FUND THE
RATES THAT THE STUDY SHOWS AE
DESPERATELY NEEDED. THE
GOVERNOR'S TALKED ABOUT HOW
HISTORIC THE BUDGET IS AND WHAT
WOULD BE TRULY HISTORIC WOULD
BE TO FINALLY. STOP SHORT
CHANGING SERVICES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY- I KNOW THAT MY
COLLEAGUES ACROSS I'LL SHARE MY
CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD THIS
STATED MANY TIMES IN THE PAST
AS A COMMUNITY WE ALL CARE
ABOUT AND WANT TO HELP. SO I
WOULD BE PREPARED TO VOTE TODAY
TO FUND THE ENTIRE RATE STUDY
BUT I AM HOPING WE CAN FIND AN
AGREEMENT WITH ALL MEMBERS- SO
I HOPE WE CAN KEEP TALKING
ABOUT THIS IN THE NEXT FEW
DAYS. AND THEN APPROVED A RATE
INCREASE NEXT WEEK AT OUR FULL
BUDGET COMMITTEE COMMITTEE
HEARING THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
MELINDA'S AND WE KNOW THIS IS
BEEN A PROPOSAL THAT IS CLOSE.
TO ALL OF US. OKAY WITH THAT I
THINK WE WILL LOOK TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY FOUR I SEE NOBODY
THERE FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS.
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN THE
GALLERIES AT SO NOW- MODERATOR
IF YOU ARE THERE. IF YOU COULD
QUEUE THE PHONE LINE FOR THOSE
WISHING TO PROVIDE. PUBLIC
COMMENT. B. R. TELECONFERENCE
LINE ARE YOU THERE MODERATOR.
ABSOLUTELY AND THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN THERE. OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM A LINE TEN
LINE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY- I'M CHRIS
BURNS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
BOYS AND GIRLS ARE PUBLIC.
SERVING HUNDREDS OF THIS YEAR
TO TWO YEARS FROM THE BUILDING
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
FROM PREVIOUSLY FROM THE LA-
RECOMMENDING THE COVERT
RELEASED PACKAGE FOR A SECURITY
PEACE. AND SECURITY TEAMS ARE
THE I SEE YOU ON THE C. HERE
CONTINUE ON PROVIDING CRITICAL
THERAPEUTIC INTERVENTIONS FOR
FOSTER YOUTH NEEDING THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF CARE THAT
ADDRESSES THEIR TRAUMA. AND
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND A
TEMPORARY RESIDENTIAL SETTING
MUCH LIKE ICU NURSES AND
DOCTORS DURING THE PANDEMIC USE
NEEDS WERE EXTRAORDINARY
ENHANCED UPON THE UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT. OTHER SECURITY P.
STAFF COMING TO WORK EACH DAY
IN FEAR FOR THEIR OWN HEALTH TO
PROVIDE THE CARE NECESSARY TO
ASSIST THESE TRAUMATIZED YEARS.
THAT DAILY COMMITMENT CAME A
TREMENDOUS FINANCIAL EXPENSE
BUT DOES A THREAT TO OUR
OPERATIONS. WHEN TREATMENT
NEEDS. CREDIT STATE YOU. AND
THIS TREND. FROM TEACHERS
HIRING. THE NEED FOR HIGH CALL
YES YOU'RE TO KEEP. THIS IS
BEEN AN INDESCRIBABLY
CHALLENGING YEAR TO DELIVER
THESE SERVICES. BUT THEY WERE
DELIVERED CONTINUOUSLY AND IN
PERSON. TO SUPPORT THE HEALING
OF THE SHOOTERS AND SAMUS
DESPITE THE OVERWHELMING **** I
THANK YOU IN REQUEST YOU
SUPPORT THE FORTY TWO MILLION.
ONE TIME FUNDING CARESSED YOUR
TT CODE RELEASE TO ENSURE THE
ONGOING STABILITY HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND YEARS FAMILIES AND
STAFF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. NINE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE- I'M SORRY EIGHT NINE
TEN YOUR- MINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS
AND I THINK HE THAT WOULD KEP
THE PUBLIC AFFAIRS FIRST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS WE
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S ADOPTION OF THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT THE FARM GROUND
RESIDENCY TRAINING PROGRAM AND
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT. WE
ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS ON THE RECOUNT TO
MAKE SURE THE PRIMARY CARE IS
POSITIONED FRONT PANEL ON THAT
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD ON THIS
WHOLE BUDGET HEARING AND THEN
ON WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
PARTNERSHIP- AND MOVING FORWARD
WE HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL AUGMENT HOW COMPUTING. TO
BUILD YOUR CURRENT CASE. AND
I'M WITH EDUCATIONAL RICHMOND
SYSTEMS IN SAN DIEGO WE ARE
NONPROFIT WE'VE BEEN IN
BUSINESS SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE AND WE HAVE TWENTY TWO
CENTER BASED FULL DAY YEAR
ROUND CENTERS. THAT ARE- SORRY
WE HAVE BOTH THE CTA FIFTY P.
R. AND B. F. P. WE HAVE BEEN
OPEN FOR IN PERSON LEARNING AS
WELL AS DISTANCE LEARNING KERR
CENTER WORKER CALIFORNIANS. WE
ALSO EMPLOY A HUNDRED AND
NINETY- PROFESSIONAL EMPLOYEES
WHO CURRENTLY DO NOT MAKE A
PROFESSIONAL H. AND I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE- COMMITTEE AND THE
SENATE FOR YOUR- PROPOSALS AND
I'M CALLING TODAY. TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THE VARIOUS
CHILDCARE ITEMS ISSUES ONE
THROUGH TWENTY SEVEN IN THE
AGENDA PART C. AS WELL THE
CONTINUATION OF THE HOLD
HARMLESS AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATE MIGHT GO TO THE NEXT
CALL CAN YOU TELL US WHO HOW
MANY CALLS WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE FIVE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE FIVE. THANK YOU
IN MY SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANKS SIXTEEN
YOU MAY BE A NEW YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON
ANDREA SAN MIGUEL FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES IN
CALIFORNIA JUST CALLING TO
COMMENT ON KEY ISSUE FOURTEEN I
WANT TO SAY WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE COMMITTEE DISCUSSION AND
CONSIDERATION THAT THEY CALL
THEIR CONCERN. ON THE
ADMINISTRATION TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL- AND ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE RECOMMENDATION
PJ TO HAVE THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE NEARER OTHER
PROPOSALS WHICH WITHIN EASY
THIRTY TWO. ALSO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT ADEQUATELY
FUNDING LABORATORY SERVICES
SUCH AS TASK PROVIDER FOR
CONNERY. AND COMMITTEE HAD ALSO.
PUBLIC HEALTH I'M- GOING TO.
AND AS IT HAPPENED SOME TIME
AND SO I CONTINUE TO APPRECIATE
ANY CONSIDERATION CAN BE GIVEN
TO THAT. 80% OF MEDICARE CAP-
ISSUE AS WELL AS POTENTIAL ONE
TIME FUNDING RELATED TO THIS
CALL BACK. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANKS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
FERRE DATING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. IN SUPPORT OF SEVERAL
ISSUES UNDER THE DH CS
INCLUDING ISSUE THIRTY ONE
IMAGE IF THEY POSSIBILITY ISSUE
THIRTY THREE AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY TECHNICAL LIMITATIONS
ISSUE THIRTY NINE THE MANAGED
CARE PROCUREMENT PROCESS. ISSUE
FORTY THREE THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT FUNDING AN
ISSUE FORTY FIVE THE FUNDING
FOR PUBLIC HOSPITALS TO FILL
GAPS DUE TO COOK AT NINETEEN
WERE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
APPROVAL ON ALL OF THESE ITEMS
WE ALSO MENTIONED THAT UNDER
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITAL-
ISSUE NINETY TO TEN DAY CLOCK
FOR RETURNING NON RESTORE BOTH.
BOOKS ARE BACK TO THE COUNTY WE
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THAT
PROPOSAL AS IT IS. CONNECTED TO
THE PROPOSALS TO HAVE SOME SORT
OF LOCAL PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
PHARMACY HOSPITAL TO HANDLE I
IT MONTHLY WELCOME TO
DEPARTMENTS IN HOSPITALS
PROPOSAL TO DISCONTINUE
ACCEPTING COUNTY PS PATIENT.
ALL OF THESE ARE CONNECTED WE
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS- WITH
THESE PROPOSALS BY THE
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITAL
HOWEVER WE ARE IN CONVERSATION
WITH THEM AND THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKING FOR A
SOLUTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MY FOUR YEAR IS OPEN
PLEASE GO. THANK YOU SENATOR MD
ACTS ON BEHALF OF S. CALIFORNIA
WE WANT TO SHARE APPRECIATION
FOR YOUR COMMITTEE SUPPORT ON
THE HEALTH BUT ALSO IN YOUR
PROPOSAL THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PUBLIC HOSPITAL
BUDGET REQUEST TO COPE THE
COVER. OF THE NINETEEN RELATED
I. T. YOUR HOSPITALIZATION
COSTS- LASTLY IN TERMS OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH THANK YOU THAT WE
DO WANN MAKE OUR LAST EFFORT
TO REQUEST A QUOTE FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ON
GOING PUBLIC HEALTH. BUT YOU
HAVE TO GO DIRECTLY TOWARD
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
HELP BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND STAFFING NEEDED TO MEET THE
DEMANDS OF THAT COMMUNITY AND
LASTLY WE APPRECIATE YOU
HOLDING OPEN. SEVERAL HUGE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH I AM FAT AND
SEE I KNEW IT DIDN'T
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT
NOT WITH REGARD TO THE LACK OF
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF ON THE REMAINING ITEMS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. BY TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK MADAM CHAIR SUPERSTAR
HALF OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATE THEY JUST WANTED TO
CALL AND ASK OUR SUPPORT FOR
ISSUE NUMBER FORTY SEVEN AND
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION ON
TELEHEALTH AUDIO ONLY TO
REJECT. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL AND ADOPT A MODIFIED
PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
CONSISTENT WITH AT THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO YOU AND
YOUR STAFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS COUNTING DOWN
OFTEN REPRESENTING EUREKA
CENTER FOR POLICY AND RESEARCH
I THINK YOU SHOULD LOOK LIKE TO
ECHO SENATOR MELINDA- COMMENT-
STARTING UP A HEARING REGARDING
THE RATE SETTING FORTH PART
DEPARTMENT. OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES- YOU KNOW THERE'S A
RATE SETTING STUDY WAS DONE
OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO THAT WAS
SHELVED- WE ARE NOW YOU KNOW
TWENTY EIGHTEEN- ALMOST TWENTY
YEARS LATER WE HAD ANOTHER
STUDY- THE RATES ARE THERE
WHICH DESPERATELY NEEDED- WE-
YOU KNOW OUR PROVIDERS CANNOT
KEEP EMPLOYEES SO- WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE.
SUBCOMMITTEE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES AND LEADERSHIP TO
WORK TOWARDS IMPLEMENTING THIS
RATE SHUTTING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY CAROL TO WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF THIS YEAR FOR THEIR- HARD
WORK ON THESE YOU KNOW VERY
ROBUST BUDGET PACKAGE THAT YOU
PUT TOWARDS HOW WE WANT TO-
ECHO- YOU WANT TO. SHOW SUPPORT
FOR ITEM FORTY THREE WHICH IS
THE INCREASE FOR THE F. AND B.
TEAM BEAT FUNDING RICHARD
REALLY- APPROPRIATE- WE WANT TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR- ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY FIVE- THE COW WORKS-
FEDERAL PANAMA PANDEMIC FUNDING
IT'S GOING TO BE GOING TO
FAMILY. ITEM NUMBER NINETY NINE
WHICH IS THE TV ALL FOR THE CAL
WORKS OVERPAYMENT PROBLEM THAT
WAS RESULTED FROM- PEOPLE
GETTING OVER PAYMENTS TO THE
PANDEMIC AND THE LAST THING WE
WANT TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR ITEM
NUMBER ONE ON ONE- THE CAL
WORKS TIME MONEY ISSUE-
PROPOSED. COMING BACK ON A NEXT
YEAR. I WE LOOK TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE GOING FOR IF YOU
KNOW THE MORE I. HE JUST GOT.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
FINISHING THE PROCESS WITH WITH
YOU ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CALLER
PLEASE. MY TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON LINDA AWAY WITH
LESSONS AND- ON POVERTY TO
COMMENT ON THE HEALTH PART H.
AND THE ITEMS WE WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR GOING BEYOND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND MEDICAID HEALTH
UNDOCUMENTED ADULT TO INCLUDE.
ADULTS AGED FIFTY. S. AS IN
IMPORTANT STEP TO GET TO ALL WE
ALSO SUPPORT I TEND TO EXPAND
POSTPARTUM ELIGIBILITY TO A
LUCKY WITH GLUCOSE MONITORING.
A COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
COVERAGE AS WELL AIRING OUT THE
COVER CALIFORNIA ONE DOLLAR
PREMIUM DESPITE SIGNIFICANT
SURPLUS WE WORK AT THE POINT AT
THE MINISTRATION DID NOT
INCLUDE. ELIMINATION AT THE NET
ACCOUNT ACTIVE YES ONE TIME IN
FACT YOU COULD TELL THAT HOW DO
YOU DEPORT SERVICES. AND URGED
THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE ACTION
ON THESE ISSUES AND FINALLY WE
APPRECIATE AGENT PLEASE
LANGUAGE. ACCESS PROPOSAL AND
REQUEST OKAY HE SHOULD BE DONE
TO BE INCLUDED I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
TO ENSURE THAT CHANGES SHOULD
PLAN TO ELIMINATE. INTO MANAGED
CARE- PEOPLE CONSUMER
PROTECTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERYMUCH. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
MODERATOR WAS AT IT. WE DO ASK
HAVE. THAT IT CA UP AT THE
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT CALL PLEASE THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND I'M
SURE RYAN SPENCER ON BEHALF OF
OCEAN AND AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN FIRST LIKE A STATE OR
SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ON ISSUE NUMBER
FORTY SEVEN THE TELEHEALTH. TO
REJECT THE MINISTRATION
PROPOSAL AND INSTEAD ADOPT THE
MODIFIED PLACEHOLDER TRAVELING
THAT'S CONSISTENT AT THIRTY TWO
KNOTS ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN JUST NINE WITH
THE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION ISSUE NUMBER
FORTY FOUR TO ADOPT
ADMINISTRATION ALSO TOOK STAND
POST PARTUM MEDI CAL COVERAGE
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NINE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WOULD EXTEND
APPRECIATION TO THE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE AND THEIR STAFF
FOR THE WORK THEIR WORK ON THE
BUDGET MY NAE IS KERRY AND
FERAL HEIN I WORK WITH THIS IS
DEL MAR CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES WE PROVIDED TRAUMA
RESPONSIVE CONTINUUM OF
SERVICES TO EMPOWER CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. OUR PROGRAMS
INCLUDE THERAPEUTIC RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT WRAPAROUND FOSTER
CARE ADOPTION AND OTHER
SERVICES WE'RE CALLING IN TO
REQUEST THAT YOU WILL
PRIORITIZE THE NEEDS TO PROTECT
THE SAFETY HEALTH AND STABILITY
OF THE HIGHEST NEEDS FOSTER
YOUTH AND THAT THE STAFF
SUPPORT STAFF TO SUPPORT THEM
BY PROVIDING DESPERATELY NEEDED
COVERT RELIEF FOR SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS. WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS
THAT DUE TO THE COLD BIT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE'VE
EXPANDED TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO KEEP UP
WITH BOTH OUR RESIDENTS TO KEEP
THEM ALL SAFE WE PURCHASED P.
P. AND THAT WE HAVE STILL I'D
NEED REIMBURSEMENTS FOR AND
WE'VE GONE WITH MANDATORY
TESTING AND THESE EXPENDITURES
THEN BACK. TO HELP TO EASE
ANXIETY AND ISOLATION OF THE
STAFF AND RESIDENTS THAT HAS
TAKEN A TOLL ON ORGANIZATION
AND SO WE'RE REALLY HOPING THAT
THE- THAT YOU ALL WILL
PRIORITIZE REIMBURSEMENTS FOR
THESE HIGH AGAIN AND ALSO TO-
TO ADDRESS OTHER CRITICAL
BUDGET INCREASE REQUESTS SUCH
AS HELPING PROVIDE. FFA. SOCIAL
WORKERS. THAT'S GOING TO VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR MUCH MY IS
WE MOVE FORWARD I'M GOING TO WE
HAVE CALLS IN GOING TO. THAT
PEOPLE LIMIT CALLS TO ONE
MINUTE- SO BE PREPARED FOR ME
TO ASK YOU TO MOVE ON OKAY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE AND COLORS.
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TIME TO ONE
MINUTE WE ARE DOING VOTES ONLY
TODAY ON THE ITEMS ALREADY
LISTED- SO MODERATOR NEXT CALL
PLEASE. MY TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHARE MEMBERS MY NAME IS ERIKA
ERICKSON AND I'M THINKING ON
BEHALF OF MIDDLE INCOME
INVESTMENT FUND WE ARE MEMBERS
OF THE C. QUALITY SHIN AND WE
<c.blue>XPRESS OUR SUPPORT TO THE</c>
CHILD CARE ITEMS ON YOUR AGENDA
THAT ARE ALIGNED WITH OUR
BUDGET REQUEST. REGARDING ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY AND TWENTY TWO
WEEKS CRITICAL FOR DATE TWENTY
TWO ONE FOR THE BUDGET TO
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR NEW TRACTOR
FACILITIES AS WELL AS FUNDING
FOR REPAIR RENOVATION AND
REOPENING GRAND. AND YOU KNOW
WE LOST A LOT OF- CHECK YOUR
FACILITY NOW WE FACE DUE TO THE
FACT THAT MAKE AN EIGHT IT IS
ONLY MADE THEIR JACK HAD THAT
THEIR TEACHER WORKING IN AND
OUT OF A CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE CALL MEETING
COULD BE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
FACILITIES BEYOND WHAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNMENT ARE.
FIGHTING OVER NINETY TO ME REFI
AND TAKING CREDIT FOR CHANGES
TO BANK UPON ALL YOUR WORK ON
BEHALF OF FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
JACKIE WITH TO THE CALIBER NINE
TOM ON THE SERVICE. AND AGAIN I
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK- WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSAL TO FULLY FUND THE NEW
STATE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INITIATIVE. WHICH HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO SUPPORT THE NEXT
GENERATION OF YOUNG PEOPLE AND
INTERVENE BEFORE CHALLENGES
COME THROUGH HERE. WE ALSO URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT CODE WOULD BE
FOR AND CHEROKEE PEAS WE KNOW
THAT'S NOT ON THE BUDGET. SO
MAKE THIS QUICK PLEASE ALSO
SUPPORT THE FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS WHO CARE
FOR A 100% OF THE YOUTH AND
INTENSIFY AFTER CARE. AND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO RESEARCH
PARENTS WHO HAVE BEEN CRITICAL
TO THE SAFETY NET. DURING THE
CODEPENDENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALL NINE
ELEVEN- I'M SORRY NINE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE ON FULL REIGN AS THE
TALLY HERE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
RELIGION HEALTH BOARD. AND I
JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
OF THE RESTORATION OF THE ONE
POINT NINE MILLION FOR THE CAL
WORKS INDIAN HEALTH CLINICS
WHICH WILL HELP TO STABILIZE
FAMILIES AND GET PEOPLE BACK
INTO EMPLOYMENT FOLLOWING- COVE
IT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRY MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
THIS IS ANNA JOHNSON WITH JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR USE ON
PART B. OF THE AGENDA AND
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ITEMS
FIFTY SEVEN FOR THE OFFICE OF
THE FOSTER CARE OMBUDSPERSON
FIFTY EIGHT FOR TRIBAL AFFAIRS.
AND ITEM EIGHTY FIVE FOR
FEDERAL COLLECTIBILITY
PERFORMER ON AND INDEEDTURNING
TWENTY ONE AND OLDER AND WE- WE
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND TO EXTEND THE INFANTS
UP TO THE PROBLEM AND Q. I
EXPECTED PARENTING FOSTER YOUTH
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
NINE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
PRODUCT OF CALIFORNIA COME
COMING IN A COUPLE OF. ISSUE
TWENTY TWO RELATED TO THE
EMERGENCY EQUITY MEASURES WE
SUPPORT INDUCTING A PLACEHOLDER
TPO ABS WE ARE ENGAGED ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO ENSURE THE
MEASURES WILL BE WE CAN UPDATE
IT. RELATED TO COVER CALIFORNIA
WE AGAIN URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONTINUE OUR COMMITMENT TO
AFFORDABILITY BY PRESERVING THE
EXISTING SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION.
THE NUMBERS ARE FINE. THE MAN
PENALTY. REVENUE ALONE IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO MAINTAIN OUR
SUBSIDY PROGRAMS GET FEDERAL.
FIRE LET ALONE ENOUGH TO MAP TO
FIND MUCH NEEDED COST SHARING
ASSISTANCE WE ALSO ASK THAT THE
COVER BACK COVER CONCERNING B.
DIRECTED TO RECONFIGURE AND
IMPLEMENT REDUCED EDUCTIBLES
AND COST SHARING BETWEEN TWENTY
THREE. AND THEN FINALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY THE TECHNOLOGY
CENTER AND ACCESS TO WORKERS
WORKING ON THE MEDICAID
EXPANSION FOR UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE- WE THANK YOU- WE THINK
THE SAME APPLICATION LEADERSHIP
AND EXPANDING OUR MANPOWER TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE FIFTY AND
OLDER AND THOSE PEOPLE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO. THANK
YOU SENATORS MY NAME IS SANDRA
GENOVA. I'M A PROGRAM DIRECTOR
WITH THE SPIRIT THAT I'M
CALLING THE DOCTOR AND SO OF
THE FOSTER FOR EACH SO WORKER
RATE. WHICH REDUCE HER FROM AND
HERMAN FOR ACROSS YOUTH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M WORKING WITH
MR. THANK YOU. THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. NINE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ON THIS EPISODE MARTINEZ
CALLING ON BEHALF OF FRESNO BUT
YOUR NEEDLES I'M ALSO CALLING
ON BEHALF OF OVER THIRTY FIVE
MEMBER ORGANIZATION OF THE
STATEWIDE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
JUSTICE. WHO RE ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
PROPOSAL FOR ISSUE ONE ITEM
ZERO FIVE THIRTY TO ALLOCATE
THIRTY MILLION OF ONGOING
FUNDING FOR- LIKE THE RNC
COMMIT TO ADOPTING TRAINER BILL
LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY A LIFEGUARD
EVEN THE THIRTY. OKAY NEEDED TO
FILL THE LEGISLATIVE VISION FOR
HOW TO TREAT THE POOR YOUNG
PEOPLE SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU
KNOW YOUR STAFF IN THE
ADMINISTRATION THANK. YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO OUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TYLER AND YOU CAN COUNT
THE HIP HOP TRACTORS
ASSOCIATION ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT PASS FOR MEMBERS FOR ALL
THE WORK ON NEXT YEAR
INCREDIBLE BUDGET- WE WANTED TO
ADD A COMMENT ON A FEW ITEMS
TODAY- AND SUPPORT I'VE BEEN
HERE FOR HIGH QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM FUNDING AND
SUPPORT. THE EXPANDED ON THAT
ACCOUNT COVERAGE FOR
UNDOCUMENTED OLDER ADULTS IN
THE PROJECT I WANTED TO MENTION
THAT WE ARE REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE CONTINUATION OF THE
ENVIRONMENT AFTER A SHORT
CONTRACT UNDER. WHICH SPOKEN ON
PREVIOUSLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CALLER. NINE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND WORK ON THE BUDGET MY NAME
IS LAURA RICHARDSON AND I WORK
FOR THE STATE WHITE FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY AND SHORT TERM.
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROVIDER- WE SERVE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN. EACH
YEAR AND WE REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE FOLLOWING
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT
RELATING TO CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES. FUNDING TO HELP
PEOPLE LIVE AT THAT PACE TO
SHOW WORKER. WORK SOCIAL
WORKERS DEBILITY IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR FACTORS FOR ACHIEVING
COMPATIBILITY FOR FOSTER YOUTH
DURING THESE SPECIALLY
CHALLENGING BEHIND SOCIAL
WORKERS ABILITY IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER FOR FOSTER
YOUTH. IN ADDITION ADMIN AND
SECURITY PROVIDER WE'VE BEEN
MISTAKENLY IMPACTED BY COVERT
NINETEEN AND REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ONE TIME FUNDING TO
HELP STABILIZE THEIR PROGRAMS
AND ALSO ONE BEHIND FINDING
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN SPORTS
FAMILIES. THAT HAVE PREPARED.
FOR YOU VERY MUCH THANKS FOR
CALLING. NINE FORTY LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE U.
TERM MEMBER SERVERS ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE STOCK RECOMMENDATIONS
ISSUE FORTY SEVEN RELATING TO
TELL. VISIBILITY TO REJECT THE
DTS PROPOSED WANTED DOCTOR
PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE AND
LANGUAGE B. THIRTY TWO
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE TOP RECOMMENDATION TO
APPROVE THE FIFTY NINE DOLLAR
APPLICATION TO FIND GROUND WORK
FIRST PROGRAM OUTLINED IN ISSUE
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINER OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE AND
STAFF- MY NAME'S MARICA CALLING
THE CONSEQUENCE OF THE
CUSTOMERS CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
LOCATED IN VENTURA AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES. WE OPERATE IN
A CHEROKEE P. AS WELL AS A
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCY I AM
CALLING TO IMPLORE THE
COMMITTEE TYPICALLY USE-
FINANCIAL DOCTOR CALMLY AGENCY
AFRICAN SOCIAL WORKERS THEY ARE
THE LIFELINE. TO STABILITY FOR
OUR CHILDREN. ARE MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN- WE KNOW
THAT FUNDING IS NEEDED TO
REDUCE THE TURNOVER NUMBERS
BEING- THE HIGH RATE OF
TURNOVER OF THE SOCIAL WORKERS
INTEREST DIRECTLY CORRELATED-
TO- INCREASING CONTROL MEDICAL
EXPERIENCING INSTABILITY TO
TRUST IN GOD HAPTIC
RELATIONSHIP SO. I WOULD
IMPLORE YOU TO PLEASE- PROVIDE
NECESSARY FUNDING PROGRAMS ARE
CROSSER RELATED TO DO SOME
WORKERS WELL TO WHAT TYPE OF
FOR THE RESTORE PLANNING YOU
VERY. THANKS LOT. THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT INSURE
MEMBERS THAT REALLY WANT TO
HAVE YOU W. WE THINK THAT
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND DEDICATED WORKER
YOUR SUPPORT OF MANY OF THE
PROPOSALS HIGHLIGHT PART B. I.
ITEM FIFTY FIVE AND SEVENTY ONE
IN PARTICULAR. ON BEHALF OF THE
V. P. YOU ENJOY PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN AT THE END YOU RAIN HE
W. WE APPRECIATE IT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS AROUND CHILD
ACTUALLY I AM TWENTY FOUR THE
POINT ATTENDANCE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT AND THE PENDING
CONTRACT THANKS SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR IS
OPEN TO GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
YOU AT THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IN YOUR STOP FOR ALL
THE IMPORTANT WORK THAT YOU
HAVE UNDERTAKEN- PARTICULARLY
AS IT RELATES TO BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS TO INSURE THAT-
THOSE IN NEED OF CARE ARE GOING
TO RECEIVE THEM I THINK I
FORGOT TO INTRODUCE MYSELF TO
BE OUT THAT APOLOGIES LIBBY
FRANCHISE ON THE ALBUM. AT THE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIA WANTED TO
REGISTER STRONG SUPPORT FOR-
FUNDING AUGMENTATIONS RELATED
THE COW WORK AND CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES AND ALSO EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR- FUNDING
AUGMENTATION FOR THE NEEDS OF
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES AT OUR
BORDERS PARTICULARLY THOSE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS AND THE
COUNTIES FOR HELPING PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR THEM TO BE A RAPID
RESPONSE FUNDING THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHAIRMAN BUT MY NAME IS SUE
EVANS AND I AND THE PLO ALL THE
TIME THE SEVENTIES THAT
PROVIDES I THOUGHT THE
CHARACTER AT THE DROP IN
CALIFORNIA I AM HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THE BUDGET REQUEST FOR
A FOSTER FAMILY AGENCYSOCIAL
WORKERS- AGENCIES CAMPUS SOME
ABOUT MY TWELVE YEAR OLD.
CHILDREN AND STABILITY OF THE
**** THE CATFISH WORK IS
CRUCIAL IN HELPING OUT CHILDREN
MORE SPEEDILY AT RETENTION
REUNIFICATION OF PERMANENCY
ALSO TO SUPPORT ONE TIME K.
WHICH REQUESTED SUPPORT OF THE
SOLDIERS FAMILIES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NINE
THIRTY YEAR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JUST AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
TO FUND IT. GOOD CORPORATE YOU
ITEMS UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THAT WE
ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT I SHOULD
GIVE YOU THE TIME TAIL COUNTY.
INTEGRATION PILOT AND WE ARE
ALSO SUPPORTED THE ISSUE FIFTY
THREE LOCAL MEDICAL COVERAGE
FOR NOT MAKING YEARS THANK YOU
SO. MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MONICA MILLER ON BEHALF
OF. SHE ITEM THE FIRST ONE IT
DIDN'T URT ANY OF THE AGENDA
TODAY- UNDER FORTY ONE AND
FORTY ITEMS AT SIXTEEN HOW
CLIMBERS DIRECTOR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. WHAT
HALF A MILE AWAY OPTION WE CAN
YOU KNOW AN OPTION RICH ORANGE
COUNTY. THE SECOND ITEM IS
UNDER PART B. ON THE APPETITE.
AND ACCORDINGLY SEVENTY EIGHT
AND NUMBER SEVENTY IT BECAME
DIFFICULT TO TELL EVERYTHING
CERTIFICATION IN A CORNER AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH I THINK YOU
CALL THE WORKING ON YOUR STAFF
AND FAMILY REALLY APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE FIFTY YEAR IS OPEN
PLEASE GO OUT. IF ANYONE AT THE
AGE CATEGORY YEAH I'M I'M PART
EIGHT- ISSUE PARTICULARLY
RIDICULOUS I'M DIFFERENT
BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE TO-
CONTINUE DISCREDITING A GREAT
SPOT. FOR MOST OF THE TIME OF
THE ATTACK AND BECAUSE THE
CORPORATE SECOND REQUIREMENT
THAT ENSURE QUALITY CARE EACH
AND THEN ON PART BE- INTO COURT
OF ITEM FIFTY FIVE TO GET THE
AGES THAT USUAL PROGRAM
PROPOSAL AND ITEM. SEVENTY ONE
H. IF YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CALLER. NINE FIFTY
SIX YEAR IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS C. B. ABRAMOWITZ
I AM CALLING FROM OAKLAND AND I
AM AN ORGANIZER WITH THE HELP
FROM CAMPAIGN WHICH HAS OVER A
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS- I WANTED
TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE
INTERNET FOR INCLUDING
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN OLDER IN
THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND PHOTO
MEDICAL PLAN DOCUMENT TO
PEOPLE- THE CODE NINETEEN OR
TWENTY. FIFTH AND IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE NO LONGER
EXCLUDE UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN CONTRIBUTING SO MUCH
TO CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY AND
ECONOMY. WITH A POSITIVE BUDGET
BACK BUT THERE'S NO EXCUSE NOT
TO INVEST IN THE INBOX MANY
COMMUNITY QUITE A PRACTICAL BUT
NINETEEN THANK YOU. WE WILL
EXTEND YOUR THANKS TO THE.
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FIND EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THERE ARE
FLOCKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK AND WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE EXPANSION OF
MEDICAID OUT TO SENIORS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS AND WE ARE LOCATED- AND
VERY PAINFUL TO SEE THAT THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY ARE
PROPOSING. TO GO MUCH FURTHER
AND EXPANDED INDIVIDUALS AGE
FIFTY AND UP WE WANT T MAKE
SURE IMPLEMENTATION HAPPENS
QUICKLY AND PRIORITISE
EXTENDING COVERAGE TO ALL
ADULTS ADULTS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. AND ALSO WE
HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL
DEEPLY IMPACT IN OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM WE NEED TO ENSURE
A STRONG INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WORKFORCE AND FOCUS ON THE
SOCIAL DIRECTED HER TO MEN
HELD. REGIONAL EQUITY AND
PREVENTION IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALL THE. WORK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
SIXTY YOUR IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBER OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MORNING- AND HE JUST
ON BEHALF OF BLUE SHIELD
CALLING IN ON AN AGENDA. EIGHT
ISSUE FIVE THE HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE LEADERSHIP
ITEMS- UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS PROPOSAL
BECAUSE THE CURRENT PROPOSAL
REQUIRED THIS YEAR STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS WITHOUT ANY SPECIFIC
GOAL WHICH WE BELIEVE WILL
UNDERMINE CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
REFORM GOAL. WE SUGGESTING THAT
HE SHORTENED PROCESS THAT
TYPICALLY ADDRESSES HOW
COMMERCIAL MARKET CAN LEVERAGE
THE POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT SERVICE. ALSO
PROPOSED IN THE REVISED AND
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR PATIENT
RECORDS THAT WE SENT OUT THE
BIBLE HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
MINDFUL FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS SALLY KING I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CANCER PROJECT
CALIFORNIA- THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK ON THE
BUDGET- ONE THING WHAT. IS THE-
CONTINUED PUBLICATION ABOUT-
BOOKING IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
COMMUNICATION WITH A ONE TIME
INVESTMENT OF THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO ADEQUATELY
FUND- KOBE OUTREACH RECOVERY
EFFORT- WE ANTICIPATE THE
FUNDING FOR DAY- COULD BE WITH
THE HELP ME HELP YOU WITH THE
SERVICE AGENCY. THE CURRENTLY
EXISTING COMMUNITY HEALTH
PROJECT OUTREACH. I LOOK
FORWARD TO SPEAKING WITH AND
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY NINE LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS VALERIE NOW AND I THINK
EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA WE ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COALITION
AND SUPPORTED A GREAT REFORM
REGULATORY AND FUNDING
FLEXIBILITY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
ARE HERE TO SUPPORT TAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ISSUE
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN TELEHEALTH
SERVICES PRODI ONLY THREE
THIRTY CONSISTENT WITH AT
THIRTY TWO. OR THIRTY FOURTH
ISSUE SEVENTY ONE I ATE AT THAT
STATE AND COUNTY SHARING RATIO
PROPOSAL TO PRESERVE IHR WAGE
INCENTIVE. YOUR MIND REMAINS
OPPOSED TO THE DISCONTINUATION
OF OUTCAST THE HOSPITAL
CONTRACT BUT CONCERNED WITH
COUNTIES AND CURRENT HI MY
DAUGHTER SHE WAS GONE YEAH
AFTER THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
THE FACT EARLY WITH ISSUE-NUMBER NINETY IN A BROADER
CONVERSATION NEED REQUIRING I.
OPERATIONS FLAPPING EARS
INTEGRATION ON THE CABINET HE
CAN'T WAIT TO REQUEST IN ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION I'M GOING
TO GO PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
IN THE WORKFORCE THANK. YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TO GO AHEAD. MY
SIXTY YOU MAY BE A NEW PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS COURTNEY JENSEN ON
BEHALF OF BILL THE CALIFORNIA-
IN REGARDS TO PART BE ITEMS
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWO ON THE
AGENDA IT IS CRITICAL FOR THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET TO
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR THE NEW
CHILD CARE FACILITIES AS WELL
AS- FUNDING FOR REPAIR
RENOVATION AND REOPENING GRANT.
WE SUPPORT THESE ITEMS IN THE
SENATE CHILD CARE AND EARLY
EDUCATION PLAN AND APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE INCLUDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
FACILITIES BEYOND WHAT WAS
INCLUDED BY THE GOVERNOR IN THE
MAY REVISE. FUNDING IS A GREAT
STEP TOWARD ENSURING CALIFORNIA
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
FACILITIES INFRASTRUCTURE HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO SERVE THE
ADDITIONAL NEW CHILD CARE SLOTS
BEING PROPOSED THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ONE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WAS
JUST IN THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES I JUST WANT TO ADDRESS
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY ONE
ON PART BE RELATED TO THE HIGH
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROPOSAL
I WILL CONTINUE TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL AND IT'S
ONE THAT. CAN FIT MINISTRATION
THE LEGISLATURE ENOUGH
PROGRESS- RESOLVING THE ONE
OUTSTANDING ISSUE WE HAD
RELATED TO THE NUMBER OF TIMES
THE COUNTY COULD USE THE 10%
OVER THREE YEARS TOOL- WERE
PRETTY CLOSE TO RESOLVING THAT
ISSUE SO PRECIADO COURT AROUND
FOR THAT IN THE- PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. NINE SIXTY SIX
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DANIEL OPEN FOR US WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENCE ACTORS CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE DEPARTMENT
EIGHTEEN A GLOBAL NUMBER THREE-
INCREASING THE BUDGET FOR
EIGHTY ARE THESE- WE REPRESENT
NUMBER OF EVERTON'S EIGHTY OUR-SEASON ARE MEMBERSHIPS- AND
INSTANTLY CENTERS PROVIDE
SERVICES TO PEOPLE WITH.
DISABILITIES AND LAUGH TWO
YEARS AND WE APPRECIATE- THIS.
ITEM BEING CARRIED FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. NINE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS A MAJOR LANGUAGE
FROM NIELSEN MARKS ARE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL AND THE PROPOSAL FROM
THE MAY REVISE IT ASSUMES THE
CONTINUATION OF THE 65% 35%
COUNTY SHARE. RATIO AND THE
CONTINUATION OF THE 10% OVER
THREE YEARS OPTION THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MACHEL CONTENDS THAT
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
VISITATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT I THANK YOU FOR THE
HARD WORK AND THE FED COMMITTEE
AND JUST AS DELIBERATIONS ARE
MOVING TO THE FULL BUDGET WE
ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO KEEP
IN MIND OUR REQUEST TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND
FOR. PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE- WHILE
THEY'RE IN THE CLASSROOM- LEAD
RESPONSE FUNDING- WE DON'T
HAVE. OKAY THE BOOK FINDING
EXCUSE ME TED TO TAKE CARE OF
OUR DAY TO DAY RESPONSIBILITIES
IN PUBLIC HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE
BEING EXACERBATED WE JUST ASK
THAT AS WELL AS THE TRACK NOW
I'M AN INVESTOR THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THAT WAS OUR LAST CALLER Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW YOU ARE
DIDN'T ET A CHANCE TO CALL OR
DIDN'T GET TO SEE EVERYTHING
YOU WANT. WE'RE STILL
INTERESTED IN YOUR INPUT SO.
FEEL FREE TO EMAIL. THE
COMMITTEE WITH ANY FURTHER
ISSUES. NOW IF THERE'S A IF
THERE'S NO OBJECTION WE WILL
MOVE ON TO SOME OF THE VOTE ON
THE BUDGET ITEMS. AND AGAIN WE
HAVE GROUP THESE- DEALING WITH
ISSUES AROUND HEALTH. HUMAN
SERVICES AND CHILDCARE. HI AND
THAT IS GOING TO BE HEALTH PART
EIGHT HUMAN SERVICE PARK P.
CHILDCARE PART SEE. SO FOR PART
EIGHT ISSUE NUMBER ONE AND
WE'RE GOING TO- PROPOSED AT
THIS BEYOND CONSENT AND THAT
WOULD BE UNDER PART A- THE
FIRST. GROUPING ISSUES ONE TWO
FIVE TWO FOURTEEN. TWELVE
THIRTY SIX SIXTEEN THROUGH
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE TO TWENTY
NINE THIRTY ONE THROUGH FORTY
ONE FORTY THREE. 452-408-5350
ONE. FIFTY FIFTY NINE SIXTY
SIXTY TWO THROUGH SIXTY SIX.
SIXTY EIGHT SIXTY NINE SEVENTY
FIVE TO EIGHTY SIX. EIGHTY
NINE. AND NINETY ONE THROUGH
NINETY FOUR IS THERE A MOTION
ON THAT. SHOW MOVED- THAT WAS
MOVED BY DR PAN. AND THAT IS
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT ALL IN
FAVOR PLEASE VOTE HI-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SEVEN HI MELINDA'S I. BY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT PASSES THREE
TO ZERO FOR THE NEXT- THE
SECOND GROUPING UNDER HEALTH WE
HAVE ITEMS- NUMBER THREE NUMBER
FOUR NUMBER TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWO NUMBER THIRTY NUMBER FIFTY
THREE NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT NUMBER SIXTY ONE
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN NUMBER
SEVENTY TO NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN
AND NUMBER NINETY SIX IS THERE
A MOTION FOR THOSE ITEMS. SO
MOVED BY DR PAN- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THOSE
ITEMS. ADMIN BY MELINDA IS NOW.
YEAH HI. THE THAT PASSES WITH
TWO TO ONE HIGHS DOCTOR PAN-
CHAIR AIKMAN KNOWS SENATOR
MELINDA IS THAT NOW TO THE
THIRD AND FINAL GROUPING UNDER
HEALTH FOR THE DAY- WE HAVE
ITEMS. 1-523-244-0240.
440-952-5450. SIX SEVENTY THREE
SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY THREE
SEVENTY FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY NINETY FIVE IS THERE A
MOTION SO MOVED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THAT MEANT BY.
LENDERS HM HI. THE PASSAGE TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR AIKMAN AND
DR PAM VOTING BY CENTER
MELINDA'S ABSTAINING NOW MOVING
ON TO THE SECOND CATEGORY UNDER
HUMAN SERVICES PART B. THAT
FIRST GROUPING- THE PROPOSED
FOR CONSENT ITEMS TWO THROUGH.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE THIRTY
ONE THIRTY THREE THROUGH. FIFTY
THREE FIFTY FIVE TO FIFTY NINE
SIXTY THREE SIXTY ONE I'M SORRY
EXCUSE ME. SIXTY ONE TO SIXTY
THREE SIXTY SEVEN THROUGH.
707-227-5772.EIGHTY FIVE
NINETY NINETY TWO THREE NINETY
THREE. NINETY SIX AND NINETY
NINE AND A HUNDRED IS OUR
MOTION FOR THOSE MOVED MOVED
MOVEMENT MOTION BY DR PANDA
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ADMIN HI MELINDA'S HI. HI THE
BEST ON CONSENT WITH THE OLD
MEMBERS OF VOTING HI- THE
SECOND GROUPING UNDER HUMAN
SERVICES PART B. THAT WEEK THAT
IS GOING TO BE ISSUES NUMBER
ONE NUMBER SIXTY FOUR THREE
SIXTY SIX NUMBER SEVENTY SIX
NUMBER EIGHTY SIX TO EIGHTY
NINE NUMBER NINETY FOUR THREE
NINETY FIVE AND NUMBER NINETY
SEVEN THROUGH NINETY EIGHT IS
THERE A MOTION SO MOVED
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THANK YOU BYE WELL IT DOES NOW.
HI A PASS TO DO ONE WITH CHAIR
AIKMAN AND DOCTOR PAN BOATING I
CENTER MELINDA'S VOTING NO AND
NOW TO THE THIRD AND FINAL THE
GROUP OF VOTES IN PART BE HUMAN
SERVICES FOR ITEMS IN. NINETEEN
THIRTY TWO FIFTY FOUR SIXTY
SEVENTY ONE NINETY ONE AND A
HUNDRED AND ONE AND A HUNDRED
AND TWO IS THERE A MOTION SO
MOVED. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SEVEN HI BELINDA'S.
BEN HI THAT PASSES TWO TWO ZERO
WITCHER AIKMAN AND DOCTOR PAN
BOATING CENTER MELINDA'S
ABSTAINING NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO
SECTION THREE. RTC THAT IS THE
THIRD AND FINAL SECTION WILL BE
VOTING ON TODAY THERE IS TO
HAVE BOATS IN THAT THE FIRST
PART BEING IT'S S. SUBMITTED
FOR POTENTIAL CONSENT AT THAT
IS ITEMS ONE THROUGH THREE I
DON'T FIVE SIX EIGHT THROUGH
TEN. TWELVE FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY
SIX IS THERE A MOTION TO AMEND
THAT TO CONSENT SO I'M SORRY
MADAM CHAIR R. WOULD YOU READ
THSE NUMBERS AGAIN I. I
CERTAINLY WELL AS ITEMS ONE
THROUGH. THREE FIVE SIX EIGHT
THREE TEN TWELVE FOURTEEN
THROUGH. TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE AND TWENTY SIX. THE MOTION
SO MOVED YES. A MOTION BY ONE
OF THE MEMBERS HAVE HAD DOUBLE
MOTIONS ON THAT A CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HI
BELINDA'S I HAVE BEEN ALL RIGHT.
SO THAT PASSWORD THROUGH
CONSENT WITH ALL THREE MEMBERS
VOTING IN THE AFFIRMATIVE AND
NOW FOR OUR FINAL VOTE TODAY
UNDER CHILD THE SECOND PART OF
CHILDCARE WE NOW HAVE ITEMS.
FOR SEVEN ELEVEN THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY SEVEN IS
THERE A MOTION SO MOVED. A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HI BELINDA'S. HI. OKAY SO THAT
ALSO PASSES THEN- WITH TWO TWO
ZERO THAT WAS SENATOR ED EGGMAN
AND PAM VOTING RIGHTS UNDER
MELINDA'S ABSTAINING THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BOAT FOR THE DAY-
WE AGAIN WELCOME ANY
PARTICIPATION FOR ANYBODY WHO'D
LIKE TO STILL CALL IN- WE WILL
BE MEETING WITH THE FULL
BUDGET- HEARING NEXT WE THANK
ALL THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK AND WITH THAT THAT WE
WOULD HAVE MOVED TO ADJOURN.
THIS MEETING.